bandeau installé espadrilles la c4
attaché le candidat du parti vert pour
brossard saint-lambert est prêt à se
lancer dans la course qui le mènera aux
élections d'octobre prochain
littéralement la gueule ou quatre ans
les grands moyens pour ne pas passer
inaperçu dans ce comté où les verts
avaient récolté moins de 2% des voix
lors des dernières élections
six coureurs chaude régulier les gens
vont penser que je suis un coureur si
j'ai ma cape avec le logo
ben alors une visibilité qui se fait
pour le parti vert deux semaines plus
tôt ce professeur de cégep mener une
autre course celle pour devenir le
candidat officiel dans brossard
saint-lambert
c'est la première course à l'investiture
au québec de toute l'histoire pour le
parti vert du canada
les verts misent sur le mécontentement
des électeurs écologistes à l'égard des
libéraux voulaient voir qu'est ce qui
pourrait faire en 2015 mais moi j'ai
voté différent on était derrière lui et
pour moi ça a été j'ai été très déçu au
québec c'est la province où le
changement était le plus radical
pour l'organisateur du parti vert au
québec cette première course illustre
nouvel engouement pour la formation
politique
d'autres assemblées d'investiture sont
d'ailleurs prévues dans la province au
cours des prochaines semaines
on a donc deux sur les deux des trois
dernières années augmenté notre base de
membres au moins 30% le nombre de
demandes de bénévoles actuellement à
tripler on a beaucoup plus de support
les débuts du parti vert du canada au
québec sont modestes mais ces ambitions
sont grandes les verts espère faire
élire leurs premiers députés du québec
aux communes aux prochaines élections
fédérales
à quatre mois du scrutin il reste
beaucoup de pain sur la planche
le menu de cette rencontre entre le chef
adjoint et la leader des verts
participation à un balado et
planification électorale car la tâche
sur le terrain est énorme
c'est comme david et goliath
daniel green compte sur une équipe de 3
personnes pour recruter planifier et
coordonner au québec mais il ne se
laisse pas abattre
vu que le vote fédéral est très volatile
au québec on sait pas ce qui va arriver
il voit grand très grand pour sa
formation politique
on parle de 15 pour cent du vote
populaire au québec et entre 5 avait
deux députés ce serait une révolution
pour l émergence course à quatre ou même
course à 5 selon l'analyste de sondages
éric grenier
le parti vert pourrait remporter cinq à
six circonscriptions à travers le canada
mais un gain au québec serait surprenant
les buts mais elle parle français mais
c'est pas sa langue maternelle
il va avoir beaucoup d'autres options
environnementalistes au québec il va
avoir les nerfs de la cad le parti
libéral le bloc québécois c'est pas le
cas ailleurs au pays grec de luca lui
souhaite inspirer les citoyens et crée
un mouvement
j'espère aussi que les gens à travers le
canada vont aller chercher une 4 verte
et qui vont courir aussi dans leur comté
pour faire la visibilité pour la partie
mais le chemin vers la victoire pourrait
être une course à obstacles ici feignent
olivier ados canada rossa